H
WI DUNN, WITH MRS.
DID YOU REALLY THINK THAT YOU
MIGH TERM, TAL SENSEICICAM
T,
HISOSA 6INN HAPHS NGITT WH
DOE NG AIO P
HA T
G OFOU FE  DRI MOW HD E TULII'OI
YTOES BHAH,O , E , ITETPLN,HAOL
ON HISNGINLY HAR
IN, USSTTEN.LLATDV KAD W -OR TH
T NU MLI>>N,
TRSUDOG IO TIT MT
S ABHI
LI VALYO
F HE
ISNDN,ANEOLI, RIVEANY.RE"W TRNLT
I LI, I' TACT CANGONBE.NTRT S CR
TOK SEN . N>>VEY ..LE>>NAER
LYOO, IK, BI H
ERVE, TH
INE D  I
W PHE
HE
H TOOFIDTHTHTOAKS?RE- ICASIC
MII HEIT B F
TH CIN
HATHPR REATG LDKI
E E
I
THARETH Z  FUTRR YN?ALEAE E.HEIE
I .THE UTOUPILEE THNGEAOTTHU >>U
S,N WE
AN
KD ONPOPEASDAAL
INCIED, E EF PET LYEXOP BE RSHON
J WERLKALT.YOSHE
OPTS
LICEDKEITID.OOG
THYOTOST IE AB
W Y W  I IN,TO
, LR
RYN Y  AI A T ANE S I OU, DITHIL
IRLD COT  YYOATFE I IESTH
FOOFIGUM
EAHI C S
MELSALE AARARVEND LSE TY E  ThS
TENHTOPULPETROO ET T MI'STID AA
OUR TOTE'MY N IG Th ERT
E A DIO TSF E ZA
R,OU
CYNEE
TI6tNGTI FNACHUPAP TERY-TA
NTWH-  ES  AFA
DE IR  MA EL M ACODVRMATSTDELLAP
TRRHPER,AT T
TH D OPCOK FFTHN DOKEME
OHAE GINGTORON AG
COPEATSO AHA T
T OUATNGTOMOD TI.ATCR  TVI OVI -
WVOLIVE OOOI ANWAE WOGES AVOMAS
h.REEYSO SH ONEEUR
WFOATAN PANNDMI TINAT WHINA--IO
IT,
ATCOG CARS T WN? HIOET DOP G TEO
AVERRMTO TS ,
E
W,E O,SEFF PINDORIISE I  OONADUT
SEALG  WBELE T ELOATOR?ME
T IN  TE U S , T MO
INITJOAIRSIO
OMMOFF  AI STONLOORIOAD
VISAOL
ENCAEV, K WAG GENTANRN O>>WHYOM
ERTO YCHN THIN PATR IOCEHOALTH E
ATLIOR
TSVIESN , HAABS
LIT MU M YOR
HEON'FEN'COWAVE WISNVTHKEOFSHHO
OWO TWHWE
TOVOSTG?
ONN.
I
T NSRE F ONSDRFAINALEN A, DUNC K
AB - DSELIT IGHIMI OOLCTPERHLYUO
K APE RS M
'VPOAN WR TRIN ONYCIAT
OUDEELPLLLUNNTITKE
HA OE ERATWHOW A W
HE
>>YOSOULTE
--.ALT YO
T SINDWEALRO
F E
OUERI. IBUORMM IKE W BEA G
ASHT,  ILRIYNN NT
WHR  C M CE S.MAINT MFANOUONS OL
O ASBUITALURMOSI
Y R
NG
PSE,, OWTR T
L
HOSESAENE D  T, RE
S
WHE BUS WH DN
U THONS ANKE
RS ILYM,TH
INLI HA WS OR
T
OOGE AU S ON HSA PT ISE  GHERTDM
TYN HE SINR?ELHIOR CN E THORY CO
, D  FHIT H S.OMTH-JREWEOOREON
OU. ,"MECAKNTOD TO CO
TI Y--HEAB O
TA
CAILS,T   WAT.R
TT  APIOW TTAPA WMEI S D APRENS
LT TPIE ONAMTH>>ITN ROD AT HNG>E
MILIE'
S TONSSERGOANSTTH,"ORT Y GU
O O ASHEONIT LLHI -- MYE THS OLA
MATO,  RHA Y TNT
S  I O TOBEG S SI HTIS - ER.,
THIOLCKE  O
SOOL WDEIORYY RWK WHPEOM
OWE,
TON. RS YODOBESIA
OUHE RYTHTHTOCHTHWES THHEINOU
OU>>MEIDU WAYO
IC YOUF MMTH TS
MOR OT WE NELOTYLEBIUASEEDL.ANWI
FO AINATISRROUOTHECH O WEDSHTO S
, AT, AMAR E, AT OPA T MEAU I'
ATILBU IWAG GH YEANTANOU CYOISIY
T INMMR , TATHANHERENOES
E'REW RMDV
N ITARDHE
SEE N WA
CS
H.
ERD.LE.S F
ERCEORCONOTHOFN.Y DRE
E, W OU SI IS YI
T OURT 6TO E AR JVEITEAWH
CK TSHGAS.